2010年的社群網站,把祖克伯創辦臉書的過程搬上大螢幕,劇本拿下奧斯卡。
寫劇本的人叫Aaron Sorkin,影集白宮風雲也是他寫的,人物講話又快又密是他的招牌。
16年後他又拍了一部臉書的電影,叫The Social Reckoning,主角換成臉書的吹哨者跟報導他的記者,美國10月9號上映。
這是紐約時報9月上架的訪談,他在裡面說他對AI很樂觀,因為他覺得AI不會成功。
訪談先談的是主客博Sulkin說
真人寫進劇本
寫到後來都會變成他自己創造的角色
那是我寫的第一篇文章
他認為他所做的事是保護美國
喬克爾和喬克爾
他們只想殺死悟空
這些人是敵人
其他人是敵人
在馬克的情況下
或者任何敵人的情況下
作為寫者
我不能批評這個角色
我寫這個角色
就像他們在向上帝說
他們應該進入天堂
你不認為馬克·扎克伯格是個敵人嗎
我們是在談真正的馬克
還是我的馬克
告訴我分別
好
我
我不想判斷真正的馬克
我不是為了這個
馬克在《社會悲哀》中
是個敵人
不是個敵人
我只是想加上
這個角色和這個人
不僅僅是我試圖抵擋他們
也有傑瑞米·弗里斯·弗里斯
他在演這部劇的時候
他一直在抵擋我
不僅是在舞臺上
他也在晚上導演我
他在拍攝的最後一天
我打開門口
傑瑞米·弗里斯·弗里斯
這是我第一次聽到他用自己的聲音在臺上
不是馬克思的聲音
他自己的聲音是
如果我參與了傑弗
我應該是在抵抗傑弗
嗯
我正確明白了
馬克·扎克伯克現在的狀況是什麼?
我想在
在
他正在
將人們連在一起
這是他從始至終的任務
呃
我認為他所做的進步
以某種技術
以AI
以及愚蠢的眼鏡
呃
那
你知道
主持人後來問到他怎麼寫作
Sorkin寫對白的時候會站起來
把整場戲演一遍
邊演邊念
他說那是寫得順的日子
我又有另一個想法
我寫了八八集《西方》
八八七次
我告訴周圍的人
各位,這就是完結了
我只用了我所知道的每一句
每一種我能想像的詞彙
我沒有其他故事
我們正在真正的麻煩中
同樣是電影中
同樣是演出中
你們的演講風格非常認可
超級聰明的人
互相交流超級聰明的故事
超級快
當然,人工智能是一個大問題
當我們在談論創作和寫作時
你有沒有被吸引到在聊天室上
讓他們做一個亞倫·索爾肯的場面?
因為我可以想象
那是一個提示
讓他們知道正確如何操作
我其實想要這樣做
謝謝
不,我意思是操作,而不是改善
我認為一個機械人就能做到
不,不,操作
因為你有一個非常明顯的風格
就是我所指的
他們會明白指引的意思
我感謝你
不,我還沒做過
但你會想聽聽我的理論嗎
你會想我告訴你為什麼
請揭露
為什麼我對AI有興趣嗎
是的
好
因為我認為它不會有效
我記得在一家晚餐會上
一段時間以前
那裡有一幅畫
是一幅粗糙的畫
我感覺很喜歡
我看著
我並不知道什麼是藝術
我用的詞詞連續詞都說不出口了
但我喜歡它
我不知道
從藝術來說
我喜歡這種感覺
會員跟我說
那是工程畫的
我感受到技術的感受
但我感覺到的那幅畫
已經不存在了
如果你是一個玩遊戲遊戲的人
如果你玩《 Call of Duty 》
你拍攝的那些人
你沒有對他們的情緒聯繫
這就是你看《AI Schindler's List》的經驗
我認為我們會發現
當你進入電影劇院
你可能不知道
那名演員的名字
那名作者的名字
我認為我們會發現
對你而言
那是一個人
但在任何地方
封鎖了你所做的困難的過程
我相信你
事實上 尤其是因為我開始想想的很困難
事實上 我想如果我去到某個網站
說 如果有機會 給我寫一個開場的故事
他能夠做到 甚至能夠近距離
我只能用語言來解釋
我覺得這就是我以後要做的一切
我再也不想再有這個想法
這就是危險
對
所以你為何這麼自信
首先 這就是我賺錢的方式
盧盧,你別在工作上試圖罵我
好吧
我真的相信
我最初想
未來可能是非AI電影
你會在藝術家裡找到
每次有時候
你會聽到有一個城市
有一個很棒的非AI電影
但我真的不相信
我想要一個像斯科西的電影
我想要一個斯皮爾伯格的電影
我想要一個阿德·麥克·K電影
Sorkin自己也承認
AI要是寫得出一場像樣的開場戲
他大概就不會再自己想點子了
他還是相信
觀眾走進戲院的時候
會在乎那部電影是人做的
原影片一個小時
Sorkin還講到
據他了解Meta
寄過信給出品這部片的Sony
片場另外請了一家律師事務所
把電影裡講到的事實一條一條核對過
他也講了2019年
他在紐約時報寫公開信批評臉書
祖克伯拿他寫過的電影臺詞來回應
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多